[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a este programa
especial del debate de France 24 el 2022
pasará la historia como el año en que
tal vez América Latina tuvo nuevamente
virajes políticos contundentes países
como Brasil Colombia y Honduras
solamente por mencionar algunos
cambiaron su rumbo político en la región
que se tornó de mayoría entonces de
gobiernos de izquierda como ven en el
mapa en el color rojo están los países
que pertenecen al espectro de la
izquierda mencionamos ya algunos entre
ellos también están México Honduras
Nicaragua Cuba Colombia Venezuela Perú
Bolivia chile y Brasil quedará ese giro
a partir del primero de enero del 2023
en color azul pueden ver los países que
son considerados del espectro de la
derecha Guatemala El Salvador Costa Rica
Ecuador Paraguay y Uruguay y en color
amarillo pueden ver los que son
considerados como digamos países un poco
más de tendencia de Centro Panamá y
República Dominicana
mientras América Latina da un giro
mayoritario a ese espectro de la
izquierda Europa hace todo lo contrario
varios países allí la derecha o la
extrema derecha han venido ganando
protagonismo en la escena política o
recientemente han ganado mayor presencia
en algunos de los parlamentos los casos
más destacados podemos nombrar a Francia
a Italia Suiza eslovenia Hungría
macedonia del Norte y Polonia que los
ven en color azul otros de los casos un
poco más moderados podemos decirlo así
Pero igualmente representativos en el
continente europeo por el avance que ha
tenido la derecha en donde han logrado
ya ser entre el 15 y el 20% de los
parlamentarios o entre las tres fuerzas
con mayor presencia en los legislativos
locales estamos hablando de países como
por ejemplo España los Países Bajos
Bélgica Austria Estonia Finlandia y más
recientemente Suecia
con estos dos virajes tan
representativos vale la pena entender
Cuáles son las coyunturas que se están
presentando en estas dos regiones en el
caso del continente europeo y América
Latina para provocar estos cambios
políticos hay similitudes en las
circunstancias tanto en América Latina
como en Europa vale la pena entonces
entender Cuáles son las causas de estos
virajes políticos Cuáles son los matices
de la izquierda en América Latina y los
matices que hay de la derecha en Europa
porque América Latina si tiene la misma
tendencia política no logra la
integración mientras que Europa que ya
está integrada en buena parte bajo el
manto de la Unión Europea está empezando
a presentar algunas fisuras o
discrepancias pero una Unión fuerte sí
se ha mantenido o por lo menos ha habido
unanimidad sobre todo para hacer frente
a temas de la coyuntura que se está
viendo en Europa en torno a la Guerra de
Ucrania y también como van a ser los
escenarios políticos para el 2023 en
ambas regiones para este especial del
debate de France 24 entonces Los invito
para que hagamos el análisis paralelo de
América Latina que va a la izquierda y
mientras que Europa va a la derecha así
lo hemos titulado y para conversar sobre
este tema hemos convocado a Paulina
astrosa ella es directora del programa
de estudios europeos de la Universidad
de Concepción en el sur de chile también
está con nosotros guillón ascari él es
analista político y periodista del se
conecta desde la ciudad de París en
Francia y aquí en el estudio de France
24 me acompaña Rafael piñeros analista
internacional profesor de relaciones
internacionales de la Universidad
externado de Colombia ustedes nuestros
televidentes como ya lo saben también
son parte de esta conversación de este
debate pueden dejar todos los
comentarios preguntas que ustedes deseen
hacer A través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter en Facebook y en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba el
debate_f24@santalogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen
todos sus comentarios nu el debate F 24
también ya para terminar rápidamente no
olviden que todos los contenidos de
nuestro programa también están
disponibles en diferentes plataformas de
podcast estamos en Apple podcast en
Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Paulina en Concepción en Chile dándole
la bienvenida a Paulina Gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en este resumen
especial de France 24 programas especial
del debate y comienzo preguntándole si
usted tiene la misma sensación de
América Latina ha dado un giro un poco
más grande digamoslo así hacia la
izquierda y Europa se ha movido un poco
más a la derecha por lo menos es a la
sensación que nos deja el 2022 cuál es
su análisis Cómo estás Santiago gusto
saludarte si bien comparto la
apreciación creo que de todas maneras
hay que hacer matices Porque cuando uno
ve el mapa como se habla de una Nueva
Ola rosada o la rosa en el caso de
América Latina y una derechización en el
caso de Europa la verdad es que hay que
ver Muchos muchos matices porque dentro
de las izquierdas en América Latina hay
muchas diferencias entre ellas es decir
el gobierno de borich no es lo mismo que
el gobierno de Alberto Fernández el
gobierno de Lula ni va a ser el mismo
gobierno de del propio Lula en los años
2000 no es el mismo la misma izquierda
de Castillo por lo tanto o Petro por lo
tanto creo que hay que hacer algunas
diferenciaciones lo mismo pasa con la
derecha en Europa una cosa es la
ultraderecha efectivamente ha llegado a
algunos países a gobernar como el caso
italiano que no tenemos claro cuánto
tiempo va a durar por una inestabilidad
italiana conocida pero también tenemos
otros casos en que el cual han formado
coalición o que no han logrado llegar al
poder como es el caso de Francia que tú
señalabas que si bien el discurso de
Manuel macron se ha derechizado pero
evidentemente ahí la ultraderecha no ha
llegado creo que en realidad lo que está
ocurriendo es que no es que esté ganando
la izquierda a la derecha están ganando
las oposiciones a un determinado Y eso
lleva estos péndulos oposiciones a los
matices y la diferenciación en esos
matices puntos para Resaltar de esa
intervención de Paulina le doy la
palabra ahora a guillón nuestro invitado
en la ciudad de París también sus
impresiones de lo que significan estos
cambios políticos en algunos casos como
lo dice Paulina oposición a pero también
en otros ha representado alternancia a
que también es importante Cuál es su
opinión
yo creo que no existe una izquierda pero
este diferente izquierda como lo vemos
también en América Latina con
sensibilidades diferentes y yo estoy de
acuerdo totalmente con Paulina que en la
misma cosa que está pasando también en
Europa con la derecha una derecha que
está dividida entre la ultraderecha una
derecha conservadora una derecha más de
digamos este más centro derecha no
tenemos un tenemos una polinización
fuerte en los dos dos regiones tanto en
en Europa que tanto en el subcontinente
latinoamericano es totalmente
diferente Pero el cambio se hace pero no
se anua fuerzamente por ejemplo en en el
caso de América Latina hubo rabias
rechazo hacia la política que también
permitió el regreso de una ola Rosa o
sea una una marea Rosa y en francés
diferente y en Europa con una una
derecha que aumentó por temas que son
diferentes seguro vamos a hablar de eso
en unos minutos y aquí en el estudio
para terminar esta primera ronda Rafael
bienvenido Gracias por acompañarnos en
el programa su perspectiva Bueno es un
placer estar acá en este programa
especial sin duda alguna yo creo que hay
que tener en cuenta un elemento central
y es que la coyuntura crítica de la
pandemia fue indispensable para que en
América Latina llegaran regímenes
alternativos de Centro izquierda o de
izquierda que fueran coaliciones amplias
que fueran uniones de partidos o
coaliciones ad hoc porque ese también es
un elemento importante si nosotros
miramos la forma en la que han llegado
algunos líderes al poder especialmente
en Colombia uno podría pensar que es una
coalición ad hoc y por lo tanto puede
ser significativamente inestable
distinto el caso de la llegada de Lula
que como lo decía Paulina si bien el
partido de los trabajadores tiene una
una característica tradicional de de
Centro izquierda yo no sé si él pueda
gobernar de esa forma en los próximos
cuatro años entonces hay que mirar esos
matices esas líneas grises que se
establecen y lo que yo veo en Europa es
que esos países de extremo como
alternativeland o marilyle pene en
Francia o algunos otros han hecho parte
del espectro político y yo en mucho
tiempo dentro del espectro político y
por lo tanto uno lo que observa es en
ocasiones tenues victorias o aumentos
importantes en el caudal político Pero
al menos en Francia en menor medida en
España han sido controlados por el mismo
sistema político cierto qué quiere decir
con esto los partidos tradicionales O al
menos algunas coaliciones han tenido la
posibilidad de seguir gobernando Porque
si bien el partido socialista para el
caso francés pues se encuentra muy
debilitado la coalición de Manuel mahón
logró hacerse al menos con la
presidencia no le fue también en las
legislativas Entonces yo observo
pérdida importante partidos
tradicionales observo coaliciones ad hoc
al lado y lado observo adaptaciones
dentro de los sistemas políticos para
dar respuesta a las necesidades de la
población muy distintas en América
Latina a las europeas pero igual
necesidades desafíos
inseguridades y temores yo creo que ese
es otro elemento importante hace algunos
años ya bastante atrás había un autor
dominico Así que hablaba de la
geopolítica de las emociones de cómo el
el los sentimientos Están volviendo una
cuestión importante a la hora de tomar
decisiones políticas y eso creo que guía
En algunos momentos la coyuntura local
para determinar el curso de la política
hacia un lado o hacia el otro A ver
quiero que entendamos entonces para
entender esta esta comparación que
estamos haciendo por lo menos este
análisis de las de las dos orillas de la
situación en Europa y en América Latina
que veamos puntos en común a nivel
social usted Menciona un punto
importante la pandemia de Kobe 19 lo que
nos ha dejado todavía tratando de
recuperarnos a nivel social y político
en algunos casos y sobre todo económico
busquemos puntos en común para para
entender Entonces los dos rumbos que han
tomado Comencemos por este lado Rafael
perfecto Yo creo que un primer momento
es sin duda alguna las dificultades
económicas y sociales después de la
crisis del 2008 el Banco Mundial
informó por allá hacia el 2010 2011 que
la que esa década del 2010 al 2020 iba a
ser una década de bajo crecimiento la
pandemia terminó de completar eso y
ahorita estamos en un periodo de
profunda inestabilidad económica y
social que se deriva de problemas
logísticos que se deriva de dificultades
para la producción de bienes y servicios
se deriva en guerra de Microchips
Entonces eso en América Latina Cómo cómo
se evidencia Un aumento significativo de
la pobreza y cuando hay más personas en
estado de pobreza hay inestabilidad
política y social hay mayores protestas
en la calle como lo vimos en Chile en
Colombia todos los países durante el
2019 2020 2021 ahí tenemos un muy fuerte
componente otro
discursos cortos pero que les llegan al
pueblo vamos a transformar la política
eso es muy eso es muy
heterogéneo eso es ahí cabe todo y nada
entonces ahí Creo que hay políticos
astutos que se aprovechan de un discurso
corto preciso lleno de esperanzas pero
que es muy difícil de administrar ganar
elecciones se torna relativamente fácil
y administrar cuatro años y construir
políticas públicas para los demás es
bastante difícil y yo creo que tal vez
un un tercer elemento en nuestro caso
particular en América Latina yo creo que
pérdida de competitividad o América
Latina es significativamente dependiente
a los recursos naturales y las
propuestas de transformación de cambio
profundo son difíciles en una clase
política que no se mueve y en una
sociedad que demanda cambios muy
profundos paso a preguntarle a John en
la ciudad de París para hacer la ronda
la inversa su opinión qué tenemos en
común en estas dos regiones que nos ha a
este escenario político
creo que también una una cosa muy clave
de esos últimos años es el desempleo hay
también en bastante bastante de los dos
partes también de tanto en América
Latina que en Europa una una ola de
desempleo también que llegó que llegó
también con la inflación económica con
la pandemia y también de una
polarización también más fuerte eso lo
comparten los dos países tanto se ve
durante las últimas elecciones también
generales también en uno de los países
en América Latina y también en Francia y
en otros países también Hablamos de
Italia otra cosa muy importante es una
voluntad una voluntad de de también
guardar una democracia yo creo que esos
países la mayoría
comparten la idea de que hay que guardar
una una fuerza también de diálogo Y eso
permitió yo creo a
los países de de llevar o sea también
una un un Digamos como un populismo no
en todos los países no en todos los
casos no en todos los partidos y eso lo
vemos que el populismo también o sea ha
tenido un aumento durante esos últimos
años tanto en América Latina que tanto
en Europa un discurso muy muy importante
yo creo que que hay que rescatar y
Paulina para cerrar esta ronda allí en
Concepción en Chile los matices y
similitudes que tenemos en ambas
regiones para para entender este estos
virajes políticos estas estos cambios
alternancias o o cambios de gobiernos
creo que esto se resume con un malestar
es un malestar que bien hace mucho
tiempo
los franceses se le llaman lagroño
porque esto es como más que estar de
insatisfechos con un gobierno
determinado y esto ha sido la
acumulación de lo que lo que han
señalado una situación económica que
viene desde el 2008 en adelante al cual
Europa le ha costado mucho salir de esa
situación de decrecimiento de recesión
que lo afectó muchísimo América Latina
también y que vinieron también este
Estas ideas de que sea que se vote por
la derecha o por la izquierda con
partidos tradicionales ninguno le
soluciona a la gente El problema del
desempleo el costo la vida y una serie
de temas sociales Entonces esto vino a
grabarse con la pandemia en la cual
América Latina y el Caribe según los
datos de la cepal ha sido el continente
o el subcontinente más afectado
económica y socialmente del mundo no
aquel que tiene las mayores muertes pero
sí en el cual se ha vivido un retroceso
justamente en El Avance contra la
pobreza
en clases medias que hoy día han bajado
de línea de la pobreza en muchos países
en el cual la reincorporación de la
mujer al trabajo ha costado muchísimo
Mucho trabajo informal entonces todo
esto se va acumulando Y evidentemente
lleva al caldo de cultivo para lo que
señalaba kirchnrón que surgen los
populismos académicamente hablando tanto
de derecha como de izquierda que se
aprovechan de esto y donde tratan de
de no tener ideológicamente un discurso
sino que eh ir a lo que señalaba también
Rafael de soluciones rápidas fáciles en
el que se separa un pueblo
iluminado virtuoso en contra de esta Eli
corrupta que les ha quitado esta
soberanía y que finalmente lleva a que
tanto
y partidos políticos de ultraderecha
como también de otra izquierda vayan
ganando también en ambas regiones
Paulina continuó con usted para
devolvernos desde Concepción hacia París
y luego a Bogotá aquí en el estudio de
France 24 pasó a preguntarle por el tema
de la democracia en América Latina qué
balance se puede hacer del estado de la
Democracia de este de esta región o
subcontinente Y qué se puede decir de
estos procesos electorales que hubo a lo
largo del año fue un año muy importante
en esa materia para la región que
balance hace usted
en primer lugar creo que una
característica que están teniendo sea
partidos de derecho de izquierda que van
ganando las elecciones porque insisto
quienes están ganando son las
oposiciones Lo que pasa que había más
gobiernos de derecha en el periodo
anterior y la característica es que
están ganando pero están ganando no
teniendo mayorías en los parlamentos en
los congresos es lo que estaba pasando
en Chile es lo que está pasando le va a
pasar a Lula cuando suma es lo que le
pasó a Pedro Castillo es lo que está
ocurriendo en muchos países donde cada
vez cuesta gobernar porque son regímenes
presidencialistas pero que al mismo
tiempo necesitan pasar las leyes con
mayoría de los congresos Y eso no pasa y
además con una polarización muchísimo
mayor una radicalización de las posturas
lo que cuesta mucho más
gobernar en ese sentido y esto es
preocupante cuando nos damos o nos damos
cuenta que los niveles de legitimidad
democrática se cuestionan la
inestabilidad la política aumenta donde
las mismas medidas que se adoptaron para
la pandemia muchas veces ponen en
cuestión la la estabilidad democrática
en muchos países y recién leía una
entrevista a al relator de la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos que
está aquí en chile y planteaba que
justamente América Latina está en una
situación muy preocupante del punto de
vista del respeto de la democracia y los
derechos humanos y cruzó desde
Concepción hasta acá hasta el estudio de
France 24 Rafael su opinión en materia
de democracia Cómo estamos en esta
región y también qué evaluación hace
usted del caso europeo que bueno sabemos
que el tema democrático allí pues
influyó mucho más que en América Latina
Pero cuál es su balance bueno el 2022
nos planteó tres elecciones grandes e
importantes Costa Rica Brasil y Colombia
y es satisfactorio ver que los sistemas
electorales respondieron a los desafíos
que se les presentaba cuáles son vacíos
Cuando tenemos una sociedad sociedades
polarizadas los resultados a veces
pueden ser por márgenes muy reducidos en
Brasil se observó y el resultado al
final Se ratificó Lula va a ser
posicionado el primero de enero y sin
duda alguna eso es positivo también es
positivo ver como un presidente como
Gustavo Petro que fue guerrillero por el
m-19 que participó en la asamblea
nacional Constituyente puede llegar a la
presidencia puede llegar a la
presidencia a través de los cauces
institucionales y por ejemplo en Chile
Gabriel boric sale elegido hay un
referendo que le dice no va a un
proyecto de constitución pero se busca
dentro de los cauces de la
institucionalidad formas para resolver
Yo creo que si Buscamos que la
democracia sea popular difícilmente lo
vamos a encontrar en especial en un
continente como el nuestro en donde las
necesidades básicas insatisfechas siguen
siendo importantes y desafiantes por lo
tanto la insatisfacción es algo con lo
que lastimosamente tenemos que convivir
porque no hay un sistema perfecto y
menos como se presenta en nuestros
sistemas y en nuestros regímenes
políticos pero al mismo tiempo hay que
decir que el fortalecimiento de los
parlamentos la independencia de los
sistemas judiciales puede ser un
elemento a destacar y que en algunos
fallos o casos muy polémicos se ha visto
que operan al menos dentro de causas
relativamente normales en Europa tenemos
otro tipo de desafíos verdad porque
pensamos que son países mucho más
consolidados en términos institucionales
pensamos que una institución como el
parlamento británico pues no nos iba a
atraer lo que nos trajo en el 2022 tres
primeros ministros eso no pasa pasa a
notar latitudes pero no en el Reino
Unido y pasó entonces hay también
desafíos derivados de una profunda
insatisfacción tal vez de malas
decisiones en el Reino Unido todavía se
debate si el brexit no y el año
inteligente o no el próximo año se
cumplen 25 años de los acuerdos de el
viernes Santo no volver a hacer Y por
qué no estamos en la Unión Europea si el
acuerdo se hizo justamente para eso
Entonces creo que hay desafíos en todo
la Box gana terreno en España y nos
damos cuenta de que a pesar de la
fortaleza institucional los gobiernos
también pueden ser inestables en Italia
desde después de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial Solo dos primeros ministros han
completado su su periodo por lo tanto la
que ganó este año puede que el año
entrante o el siguiente tal vez no esté
entonces las inestabilidades se producen
por por temas por coyunturas críticas
puede que un conflicto como el de
Ucrania y la asimilación de personas en
en desplazamiento forzoso o en búsqueda
de Refugio o una situación en el norte
de África o lo que se viene ahorita para
los próximos meses que es un fuerte
invierno pues puede hacer tambalear
preocupar o generar desafíos sobre la
estabilidad de los gobiernos que estén
hoy no y no sabemos cómo cómo solucionar
esa situación Vámonos al otro lado del
Atlántico
último en esta ronda para preguntarle
justamente por el caso europeo porque
también vemos allí unos escenarios
políticos
pues muy poco comunes o por lo menos
para lo que uno conoce la historia de la
Unión Europea reciente este surgimiento
de tantos movimientos nacionalistas este
sentimiento también dentro de las
juventudes de generar una gran identidad
de país y no de un bloque comunitario y
y los mismos movimientos que hemos visto
que han ganado un poco más de
posicionamiento en los parlamentos y en
los gobiernos desde la derecha y desde
la ultraderecha en algunos de los casos
A qué se puede deber Esto está
inconformidad al interior de la Unión
Europea cuando se tienen buenos sistemas
de bienestar cuando se tiene buena
infraestructura y cuando se tienen
ciertas garantías
creo que la primera respuesta a su
pregunta es también la realidad de cada
país O sea en cada país de Europa Pese
que sea un bloque Pese que se que tiene
una historia en común hay una realidad
diferente con una economía diferente que
está impactada por la la inflación
también de manera diferente y con
también o sea preguntas también que son
diferentes y debate que son diferentes
al dentro de los congresos cuando vemos
el caso por ejemplo de Italia o de
España es el tema de la inmigración
también lo vemos también con con Francia
es un tema muy importante que que
durante años no hablamos tanto de la del
del de la inmigración como ahora
entonces vemos que hay un cambio también
muy importante en eso y en los países
también hoy día de de también de del
este de de Europa vemos que también la
guerra en Ucrania también
revelado también también que que es
totalmente diferente la situación entre
hace 20 años y hoy donde la pregunta de
la seguridad también es una pregunta que
viene sino la primera pero en segunda en
segunda ronda también ahora en los
debates de los congresos entonces vemos
que ese ese oje de la de del extremo
también de la ultraderecha también en
Europa Está también debido también a
todas esas realidades que son diferentes
que son no son iguales por todos los
países y que forman de una manera una
polarización más fuerte cada año
por qué también hay una existe una un
curioso si existe una derecha y una
izquierda también dividida Pensé que en
Francia hubo una Unión con la nuez lo
que no se ve también en todos los países
y y vemos que también está por
idealización llega al pueblo a hacer a
decirse o decirse Bueno también es una
pregunta que tenemos que pensar que no
pensábamos antes y ahora que tenemos que
claro que hablar más
continuo con ustedes allí en París
Este modelo de la Unión Europea es un
modelo que está presentando ciertas
fisuras es un modelo que necesita ser
ajustes no estoy diciendo ni que vaya a
colapsar ni que se vaya a acabar ni que
esté presentando problemas simplemente
pues ya han pasado varias décadas con
diferentes procesos de integración con
muchos retos por delante que ha tenido
la Unión Europea pero siempre pues hay
que apretar un poco las piezas del
andamaje tal vez Europa está en este
momento en el que toca tomar una postura
frente a la defensa toca tener una
diplomacia mucho más certera un manejo
con las relaciones con Rusia por ejemplo
mucho más directo agresivo digámoslo así
en el buen sentido de la palabra para
para conseguir resultados y no ser hay
veces ese
que no se sabe cuál es el rumbo que
quiere tomar en la escena internacional
por ejemplo con el tema de Ucrania lo
digo porque muchas veces Rusia no ha
querido hablar con la Unión Europea y
quiere saltarse directamente hasta
Washington para negociar Europa Tal
parece que no lo ve como un actor
necesario con el que tenga que
relacionarse Moscú
Claro en esa guerra de en Ucrania vemos
que que que en el caso de de Rusia
también hay una posición que cambia
también con este esos líderes Estados
Unidos china Rusia y que la Unión
Europea también
hoy día también con la inestabilidades
tanto económicas sociales que conoce
tiene también que regresar a una
posición fuerte
diplomática también y también hacer
escuchar su voz vemos que también hay
muchos cambios en Europa y una
polarización vemos Que hay muchos
también este crispaciones también
alrededor de temas Como por ejemplo la
pesca lo vemos en flan ya lo vemos en
Reino Unido Y eso son temas muy
importante que afectan bastante la
economía Entonces yo yo creo que que en
eso hay dos cosas que hay que descartar
una Rusia que también que que da la
espalda también a los países que no que
no abren la puerta entre comillas a un
diálogo porque así le ven Vladimir en
esos momentos se dice que es un poco
solo ese aislado un poco de de su lado
con los países del este y del otro lado
hay países también como Francia como
Alemania esa guerra nuclear también ha
permitido también de llevar también una
Unión y también de en unos unos temas
muy importantes como como lo decía como
la seguridad el tema de la seguridad y
también le añado un ingrediente a
Paulina para esta misma pregunta de las
fisuras o de problemillas dentro de la
Unión Europea el tema del liderazgo se
fue Angela Merkel y un poco la Unión
Europea quedó como sin un sin un rumbo
un Norte justo haciendo frente a la
situación en Ucrania Cuál es su opinión
sí efectivamente yo creo que tienen un
problema de Liderazgo
hay fisuras en la en esta en este núcleo
Franco alemán
digamos que Emmanuel macron No
necesariamente se ha llevado bien con
olafones hay críticas también a lo que
fue la dependencia y aquí viene la
críticas de Ángela Merkel y Alemania en
general con de parte con gerald de la
dependencia del gas y el petróleo Ruso y
Eso si bien por un lado ha significado
que la guerra en Ucrania
ha demostrado hasta ahora con algunas
matices pero en general una Unión que ha
establecido sanciones que ha apoyado
Ucrania y que En definitiva están
pensando en esta autonomía estratégica
llevaba mucho más adelante de todas
maneras
Europa evidentemente tiene sus
complejidades cada país está está
digamos expuesto de distinta manera a lo
que significa
el gran desafío que plantea la Guerra de
Ucrania y nos vemos un liderazgo muy muy
fuerte o sea donde mirar
y creo que eso de alguna manera se ha
reflejado también en en alguna de alguna
forma que no se avance mucho más rápido
en algunos temas pero se han roto tabúes
y y Si vemos que la necesidad los ha
llevado a poner dinero sobre la mesa y
además ahora están con el tema
energético y la transformación
energética que deben acelerar y que el
hecho que estén que sean 27 países
dentro del bloque no quiere decir que
todo se lleven fantásticos Ya vimos hace
unas semanas la relación entre bienes
bucarest quedó en el Limbo después de la
decisión de no permitirle a Bulgaria y a
Rumanía entrar en el tratado de libre
circulación generó muchísima
controversia para el cierre de este
bloque Rafael adelante Bueno yo creo que
también hay que tener en cuenta elemento
central que tú mencionabas y es el
ajuste de las de las de las tuercas o o
de el andamiaje político Y es que
también hay una realidad y es que en los
últimos 70 años la Europa que nosotros
conocemos hoy la Unión Europea ha sido
producto de múltiples crisis y las
crisis han servido para potenciar el
modelo le pongo un ejemplo en el 2020 se
criticó con vehemencia desde Italia y
desde otros países los problemas
logísticos que tenía la Unión Europea
para entregar ayudas de una manera más
rápida ventiladores insumos médicos
etcétera etcétera En el último
presupuesto de la Unión Europea Italia
aseguró recursos por 208 mil millones de
euros para los próximos años Qué quiere
decir eso es cierto que lo que usted
menciona la visión estratégica de Europa
en fuerte en seguridad y defensa se vio
trastocado por una Guerra de Ucrania en
donde yo se borre él no es un
interlocutor válido sino son las
distintas capitales europeas con eso ha
habido que lidiar en los últimos 70 años
pero también el riesgo de tener un más
agresivo más fuerte en Europa es muy es
muy acuciante es muy importante y por lo
tanto si podemos utilizar todos los
mecanismos
a disposición dentro de la diplomacia
dentro de la economía dentro de la
presión social para alcanzar objetivos
políticos mucho mejor que utilizar el
uso de la fuerza o La amenaza con el uso
de la fuerza eso también hay que tenerlo
como como en el radar ahora bien Es
cierto que hay problemas derivados de la
interacción normal entre 27 aliados pero
el hecho de que haya pesos y contrapesos
el hecho de que las instituciones
medianamente resuelvan problemas y de
que las personas del común sigan
percibiendo que la integración es útil
recordemos que hay otras muchas
políticas que hoy son comunes que se
hacen comunes pero que sin duda los
estados han reservado ciertos elementos
de intergubernamentalidad por ejemplo
este año cumplimos 20 años de haber
celebrado el el el inicio del euro
cierto el inicio oficial del euro pero
no hay una política fiscal no hay una
política de crecimiento económico
comunitaria los países siguen teniendo
una muy fuerte causa entonces a veces
hay que convivir como con todo lo que
significa la intergubernamentalidad ese
es un principio importante con todo lo
que significa los principios
comunitarios y con otro importante la
subsidiaridad Europa funciona a través
de la subsidiaridad Qué es eso que actúe
la institución que sea más eficiente
para hacerlo si en ocasiones es el
estado nación que siga siendo el estado
si puede ser lo comunitario que sea lo
comunitario si es la municipalidad que
sea la municipalidad la que resuelva los
problemas y por lo tanto el desafío es
como seguir siendo coherentes Y cómo
seguir siendo eficientes dentro de los
distintos niveles de administración
pública que hay al interior de Europa
porque hay políticas que ya no van a
depender que no volverán a ser de los
estados sino que dependen evidentemente
de un ámbito comunitario Claro que sí
pues se nos acaba ya el tiempo me queda
un par de minutos para finalizar
programa se fue más rápido el tiempo de
lo que pensaba pero tiempo para llegar a
las a las conclusiones comienzo entonces
con en la ciudad de París conclusiones
perspectivas de lo que se puede esperar
para el año 2023 rápidamente retos para
Europa y América Latina en cualquier
ámbito político económico social como
usted lo quiera comentar
bueno en el caso de América Latina no
podemos hablar de un cambio total cuando
cuando sabemos que los congreso la
mayoría son O sea no es una alternativa
total porque los congresos son en
general de la derecha y ahora tenemos
una una hora de izquierda pero creo yo
creo que será una otra página una una
nueva era un nuevo cambio tanto lo
esperamos también con se va a mejorar al
nivel también económico también con la
llegada también de delurada Silva
también al poder yo creo que eso va a
haber mucho cambio también en Chile
también con con acuerdos que se hizo
también para un instituyente y que en
Perú donde hay que seguir yo creo que
también eso muestra también un balance
que hay otros países a comparación donde
también será difícil también de evitar
una crisis en Europa también Creo que va
a ser la misma pregunta va a ser también
de este tener una estabilidad y de
también una salida a lo que es la guerra
en Ucrania que no se ve hasta el día de
hoy y también
conseguir también a a tener también unas
respuestas a la infracción económica que
muy fuerte por los dos partes del mundo
rápidamente Paulina su conclusión
perspectiva la verdad que no soy tan
optimista como en el caso de América
Latina Creo que no va a haber grandes
cambios en como uno Espera los desafíos
son indudablemente el tema económico el
2023 viene muy fuerte para para América
Latina la inflación la estabilidad
política Creo que van a ser grandes
desafíos y no yo no pondría tantas
fichas en el caso de Brasil porque Lula
le va a costar gobernar y lo primero que
va a tener que hacer es tratar de tomar
un cierto control porque ganó por muy
poco y tiene un congreso en contra en el
caso de Europa desafíos principales
evidentemente la guerra el tema
energético que ya están trabajando de
manera muy fuerte en eso
vienen las elecciones de las autoridades
y del parlamento europeo y ahí puede que
tal vez estos partidos
que si bien no quieren abandonar la
Unión Europea la quieren transformar por
dentro y eso también puede ser un
desafío bastante grande el tema de la
otan también es otra otro tema y Rusia
lo va a seguir siendo sin duda como
China y aquí para el cierre Rafael bueno
en efecto en América Latina coincido con
Paulina en que el 2023 puede ser un año
casi que de recesión económica las
perspectivas de la cepal y del fondo
monetario internacional alertan de un
muy bajo crecimiento Y eso pone en
aprietos algunos de los problemas
algunos de los programas que
tradicionalmente utiliza los regímenes
de Centro izquierda y es más gasto
público Ahí va a haber una dificultad
importante que no va a ser fácil de
sortear desde el punto de vista político
en octubre del 2023 Argentina irá a
elecciones y puede ser un cambio
significativo para el inicio ciclo en
2024 donde distintos países van a tener
elecciones entonces hay que pararle
atención a eso coincido con Paulina en
el Continente Ah bueno en América Latina
también hay importantes elementos
derivados de la transición energética
vamos a ver cómo se materializa eso y
qué forma empieza a tomar las políticas
medioambientales para los países en
América Latina de transición y en Europa
se seguirá hablando de de transición hay
que pararle bolas a las elecciones de
Turquía
en junio y sin duda alguna si hablamos
de un proceso de negociación en Ucrania
tiene que haber un proceso de
reconstrucción con esas conclusiones nos
quedamos gracias a nuestros invitados
por haber estado con nosotros en este
programa especial ustedes Gracias por la
sintonía la producción estuvo a cargo de
Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera siga
con nosotros
[Música]